Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es obtener
un poco más de práctica en la construcción de
diagramas de Lewis, en particular vamos a intentar
construir el diagrama de Lewis de un formaldehído.
Los formaldehídos tienen 1 carbono, 2 hidrógenos
y 1 oxígeno, CH₂O. Así que pausa el video e
inténtalo, trata de construir una estructura o
diagrama de Lewis válido para el formaldehído.
Ok, vamos a hacerlo juntos. En el primer paso
debemos pensar en todos los electrones de valencia
para esta molécula, y esto lo hemos visto en
videos anteriores: vamos a contar los electrones
de valencia. Ahora, la razón por la que queremos
hacer esto es que mientras intentamos crear su
estructura haremos uso de todos los electrones
de valencia. Para encontrar cuántos electrones
de valencia tenemos en total podemos observar
la tabla periódica de los elementos. Podemos
ver que el carbono se encuentra en la segunda
fila, es decir, en el segundo periodo, entonces
su segunda capa es su capa externa, y en esa
capa tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4 electrones de valencia,
por lo tanto, el carbono tiene 4 electrones de
valencia. Un átomo neutro de hidrógeno libre
va a tener 1 electrón de valencia, pero tenemos
2 de ellos, entonces será 2 x 1. Por último, el
oxígeno también está en el segundo periodo, y en
su segunda capa tiene 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 electrones
de valencia, entonces el total de electrones de
valencia en esta molécula es de 4 + (2 x 1) + 6,
lo cual es 12 electrones de valencia. Ahora, el
siguiente paso es intentar dibujar una estructura,
intentar dibujar los enlaces sencillos. Una
pregunta clave es ¿cuál creemos que va a ser
nuestro átomo central? La regla general es que
el átomo menos electronegativo que no sea el
hidrógeno será el mejor candidato para nuestro
átomo central. Entonces podemos descartar al
hidrógeno y tenemos que decidir entre el carbono
y el oxígeno. Bueno, sabemos que el oxígeno es
uno de los átomos más electronegativos, de hecho
es uno de los elementos más electronegativos en
la tabla periódica, muy cercano al flúor, por lo
tanto, el carbono es un buen candidato para átomo
central. Así que pongamos el carbono por aquí
y pongamos estos otros átomos alrededor de él,
podemos llamarlos átomos terminales; entonces
pongamos al oxígeno por aquí y luego tenemos
2 hidrógenos: uno por aquí otro por acá,
y vamos a dibujar los enlaces: este es un
enlace sencillo que representa 2 electrones de
valencia, este otro enlace sencillo representa
2 electrones de valencia y este otro representa 2
electrones de valencia, así que hemos usado 2, 4,
6 electrones de valencia por aquí. Entonces, si
restamos 6 electrones de valencia nos quedaremos
con 6 electrones de valencia. El siguiente
paso es asignar los electrones de valencia
restantes tratando de llegar a la regla del
octeto para los átomos que no son hidrógeno,
y por último intentaremos que los hidrógenos
tengan 2 electrones de valencia. Tres:
asignar los electrones de valencia restantes. Muy
bien, empecemos con este oxígeno: este oxígeno ya
comparte estos 2 electrones aquí, entonces, para
llegar a la regla del octeto, necesita 6 más, así
que vamos a dárselos, 6 electrones: 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6. Con esto acabamos de usar los 6 electrones
restantes, ya no tenemos más. De cualquier manera
vamos a ver cómo se sienten los otros átomos:
el primer hidrógeno es capaz de compartir estos
2 electrones que están en este enlace covalente,
así que se siente bastante bien, puede pretender
que tiene completa su capa más externa, ya que
su capa más externa es justamente la primera,
y ahora está completa con estos dos electrones;
lo mismo pasa para este otro hidrógeno. Entonces,
al menos los átomos terminales, el oxígeno y los
2 hidrógenos, sienten que tienen completas sus
capas externas. El cuarto paso vamos a observar
nuestro átomo central: cuatro, observar el átomo
central. ¿Necesitamos más enlaces o necesitamos
hacer algo interesante por aquí? Podemos ver que
el carbono es capaz de tener 2, 4, 6 electrones
a su alrededor, pero le encantaría tener 8, al
carbono le encantaría tener completa su capa
externa, ¿cómo logramos eso? Bueno, podemos
agregar más enlaces, pero ¿de dónde podrían
salir esos enlaces? Bueno, se obtendrán de algún
par solitario de electrones. En esta ocasión,
los únicos pares solitarios de electrones son los
que tiene el oxígeno, así que qué tal si tomamos,
digamos, este par solitario de electrones y
construimos con ellos otro enlace covalente.
Con esto nuestro diagrama de Lewis se va a ver
así. Vamos a dibujarlo de nuevo: tenemos nuestro
carbono, después tenemos nuestros 3 enlaces
covalentes originales, tenemos 1 hidrógeno,
otro hidrógeno, después tenemos nuestro oxígeno
justo aquí. Y ahora vamos a formar un nuevo enlace
covalente justo así. Y después tenemos estos
otros dos pares solitarios de electrones alrededor
del oxígeno, vamos a dibujarlos: dos y otros dos
alrededor del oxígeno. Y esto se ve bastante bien.
Esta vez el oxígeno tiene 8 electrones, 4 de ellos
en pares solitarios y 4 de ellos en este enlace
covalente doble que comparte con el carbono. Los
hidrógenos siguen con 2 electrones, son capaces
de compartir electrones con el carbono en cada
uno de estos enlaces covalentes, y, por último,
el carbono participa en... Podemos pensarlo como
4 enlaces covalentes: 2 simples y 1 doble, y como
cada uno de ellos tiene dos electrones asociados,
entonces el carbono tiene 8 electrones ahí.
Así que aquí tenemos la estructura o el
diagrama de Lewis válido para un formaldehído.